the skill itself is being able to detach
during the event the hard part is to
notice you gotta look for those signs
you gotta look for that moment when you
start feeling emotional or you know that
it's gonna be something emotional you've
got a step back from those and get get
yourself in the habit of asking yourself
what do I look like right now what do I
sound like right now listen to the words
that are coming out of your mouth and
see if you're being a reasonable human
or not look for the emotional quicksand
and don't step in it the emotion of the
anger the frustration when you start
feeling the sweat beating up when you
start feeling hot that should be a big
red flag there it is that's the
quicksand of emotion you don't want to
step into it want to pull yourself back
you